feathers are very important in the
cabaret a show without rhinestones in feathers
without sequins and well it's not a
show at all you have to bring some
feathers because it's alive
because it moves well because here's its
cover  atmosphere
[Music]
hello my name is and I'm directing and I
'm in charge of the workshop maison
c'est vous
maison avril has existed since 1929
it was mainly to make
headdresses and ornaments then the house
specialized in the costume of the  music hall
we've worked to try to get
back together
josephine baker zizi jeanmaire all
these fellows there have only progressed
so far
the feather workers bring speakers their love of feathers
brings life to the costumes everything is
handmade we use  always the same
deal tools from years ago when there is
a headdress with 300 feathers to cut
out of thirty dancers, that's a
lot of preparation work
[Music]
all our feathers come back
from bird breeding  waters for the feathers we do not
kill the birds to obtain their more
we must use for the creation of our
costumes only feathers recognized as
the ostrich doing the [ __ ] law the
guinea fowl and it is important to keep this
trade very French  is so rare
so it's very useful now that we can
keep our know-how and
pass it on from generation to generation
[Music]
to see our creations on stage is
always a pleasure
it's wonderful it's magnificent
strong that the dancer
wears it each plumassier is happy to see their
work finalized and highlighted by the
dancer and this is the reward for
all this work upstream the Seynois and
it's me of costume preparation
it's the  beauty itself
[Music]